you've been sitting out there with the
[ __ ] family thinking about killing
yourself and now look at you you here
with us for a free church a little pre
Church a little Sabbath bloody inside
oh [ __ ] Lee it's that [ __ ] time
[ __ ] you people been lounge and
bullshitting talking amongst yourselves
bad-mouthing your [ __ ] country Hilary
and this and that and this now is post
time mother [ __ ] now it's time it all
comes up we got stars of debt we got
depth of stars we got everything it
tonight mother [ __ ] is to count down
to your [ __ ] brain okay that's the
way I look at things
I was nervous man on anything was enough
what's going on
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's the Lord's Day [ __ ] yeah I'm
saying either you're getting down a
little stab you like Jesus I'm here my
[ __ ] clothes buddy Lisa at for
another fun-filled Sunday night we got
the candle in case you want to shoot
heroin San lázaro is here to give you
your last rites the devil is here and he
wants you
we got the stars of death not many but
we're making an effort the [ __ ] is this
league does Amateur Night here tonight
one and pills two and [ __ ] you guys
thought we forgot about you we never
forget about you [ __ ] we love you
too much oh [ __ ] we're starting off with
eight hundred apiece tonight we start oh
[ __ ] nine just the perfect size for a
good [ __ ] night you understand me
insane not America's birthday what do
you got - here you go one oh [ __ ]
- and these are the 200 milligram 1/3 I
like to count only I'm remembering my
numbers deep tonight [ __ ] I
don't even know stories but your
grandmother's coming for the 4th of July
she has Alzheimer's
that's perfect you bought one of these
shotguns in a [ __ ] eyeball and it's
over she'll remember everything she
remember the first dick she sucked in
1922 and these bonds are real
[ __ ] this ain't no [ __ ]
Susquehanna we from [ __ ] didn't get them
this is good week Joey I grew this I
don't give a [ __ ] you ain't smoking well
would smoke him and how was smoking this
[ __ ] Lee you got 3,000 you sure
I'm watching him so hang on man I gotta
watch this [ __ ] always trying to
put a stop buying me saves him for his
girlfriend I was dusting and I'm saying
just to make sure you didn't think you
were pulling a Louis L'Amour on Uncle
Joe him these stars like a week and a
half old [ __ ] cement and the [ __ ]
TAC just gets stronger stop looking at a
lady it's not a [ __ ] museum that's
all right only three-quarters of the
other one
tell [ __ ] that wide open you might need
three quarters or the other one you see
I'm saying right always got a read on
self never rat on yourself
[Music]
what you think of it going
one doesn't end uncle Joey never bong
hits for [ __ ] life
now it's least turn probably finish this
look to finish you started with the
[ __ ] star okay with this Bruno Magli
sure now only these is the Oh Jake loves
these open looking guide that bung it's
wavy it kind of second stories it's just
a smoke death kill that sandwich look at
here we go here we go people
shuffling [ __ ] nails get there's a
note warning [ __ ] train you look like
a savage little there you go there you
go see that's that real teeth see
cooking your bloodstream training you
gotta get into every [ __ ] day the
murky waters the murky waters of the
reefer world is a beautiful block of the
world is either you in or you out don't
come to me with you know jelly yeah I
can only do one bong hit because I have
to go to my daughter's recital that
that's even more of a reason to go deep
if your thought is like might door that
musics [ __ ] horrific
look at periscope lemon Cousteau gee and
when in doubt when you're looking to get
knocked out
gorilla glue number [ __ ] oh [ __ ] look
at me I look like a [ __ ] dude on
Tuesday at the 4th of July
[ __ ] I'm missing a thumb you like that
one we improvise here [ __ ] it's
not all melted man oh [ __ ] it's the bat
ball Jesus Christ look at him he's not
gonna [ __ ] over that's not a little this
lease mother's go a little tumble tumble
in this war this is number four smothers
you people have no [ __ ] idea number
twenty-two it don't matter is number
four is beat from the jungles oh you it
smells like cat piss and [ __ ] dead
blood oh my god it's [ __ ] tremendous
you people you don't know what you're
missing
yo they're waiting for them to legalize
California weed whoever the [ __ ] you
live it don't the wait is over details
are coming to you right now
let's go ponder this gorilla glue then
wait for my girl you know ain't got no
fireworks oh I gotta make fireworks go
off of my [ __ ] right now that that's
how we do it he understand me
you wanna [ __ ] around [ __ ] around on
your own time take that bond out hey
Lisa
we're going that's all right you this
how you get your [ __ ] lungs to shape
it this is this is THC cardio this is th
this is TAC cardio right here 101 this
is the one that takes you into the murky
waters of the underworld here we go a
little [ __ ] fairies wet boots [ __ ]
that [ __ ] they go hey don't be
sassy deep in the murky waters
you don't see I'm trying to go slow but
it seems like you go fast
you're gonna lot of things somewhere by
nothing I got you covered here you're
good at a lot of things leave people
bill a lot of things just practice makes
perfect
okay if you want to do professional fun
it's fill this [ __ ] up gotta
have goals aspirations you know I wanna
do something I'm saying you can't sit
there playing [ __ ] well is it
PlayStation 3 whatever the [ __ ] it is
I'm an old man I don't even play [ __ ]
[Music]
is all that you do
[Music]
doctor police 14 days
stop blowing bong it's like a [ __ ] and
getting a vapor to fake and [ __ ] and
don't do nothing for nobody
you get doctor police's book and you
practice it bunga's it's all over
I got lumps all the way down to my
[ __ ] kneecaps I'm saying it's when I
got something on top of me I [ __ ]
panic but there is no panic in this
world you take the bondage slowly you
meditate on it you know that the bad
smoke is the bad [ __ ] or [ __ ] that comes
out and everything is gonna be beautiful
we [ __ ] you think you're dealing with
here some Swami from salami I'm a
[ __ ] jerk-off and I know that chicken
you imagine you people educating your
family that's what I look at those
eyeballs look at this [ __ ] right here
we're going deep with Black Sabbath for
all you [ __ ] savages on Twitter you
know I love you instead of doing it on
Twitter tonight I'm doing it live for
you [ __ ] okay I'm playing we
sold my soul for rock them wrong giving
you the best they got
for the first six [ __ ] atoms first
five albums I'm sorry
this was the six technical ecstasy was
number seven technical ecstasy is like
The Fight Club you never talk about
Fight Club you never talk about
technical ecstasy then never-say-die
came on boy understanding and beside
that what the [ __ ] it's a Sunday three
fourth of July let those bonnets rip why
you [ __ ] playin what we do with this
talk what do you think we could send it
to you it'll get there we put it in the
mailbox Tuesday I'll get down Friday
[ __ ] it but I see you next time I'll
drop a star in your right now there you
go three thumbs for you this time it was
last time I ate three you got two let's
go you Stephanie staring at work is a
man like it's a [ __ ] a sports betting
program
what's with the look and what's with the
analyzing uncle Joey gives you something
you pop it close your eyes and say Lord
keep your eyes on my back yeah I'm
saying
worst case another joy give me a right
I'll give you a right on me to do it
trip up by yourself
put on pay for I wish you were here and
just sit there and [ __ ] think about
what you want where I'm saying maybe you
didn't go wrong I went wrong and that's
where I think about maybe you didn't go
wrong maybe you're [ __ ] perfect I
don't [ __ ] know I know it's it's the
Lord's Day baby
that's right in lucite leaves ready for
another bundle it loves together you
know I love you [ __ ] on the 4th
of July we're gonna leave looking pretty
for America [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] you think you'd do with the
[ __ ] we got open the door before all
building blows up from THC smoking this
[ __ ] every office has got this
[ __ ] thing last we've got a complaint
that what they say the reefer is drunk
yeah you [ __ ] either we're
going deep but you say another bong hit
I was thinking the same [ __ ] thing
myself you understand me
we're gonna stick with this Gorilla Glue
because I tell you what I'm thinking
real is right now in fact one of them
just got shot the kids flying through
the air
[Music]
alligators come later you know same but
since that time for another [ __ ]
death hit of debt with uncle Joey this
is the segment score that's it of debt
with uncle Joey okay you come up with a
better name give me the [ __ ] better
name but right now
[Music]
my ears are ringing I'm hearing Chinese
people
I hear running I have people yelling and
screaming it's like [ __ ] purgatory
but that's the reef that's the beauty
you got accepted to read our lives and I
did still hear our last goodbyes oh [ __ ]
what something now oh my days look at
that Jesus if you want a plane right now
the plane with a rattle what's going on
captain we ran into a big smoke cloud
right here
we don't [ __ ] around people I've been
telling you that [ __ ] since how are we
doing the podcast for now episode don't
these [ __ ] don't know you know
I don't know nothing all I know is you
and us we get together
what's up wait what's with that said
leave setting up me with long Joey what
the [ __ ] you gonna give me a bong hit
you like [ __ ] itch without edge Sipho
Lee one more bomb him you'll getting
sleepy
wake up [ __ ] suck umple Joey here giving
you the best I got you [ __ ] night you
know I'm sitting there like jungle we
can't do no more here you're [ __ ]
crazy oh [ __ ] a little sweetly for you
[ __ ]
suck that Soulja leak there you go
you're a [ __ ] animal that's the one
that killed Kennedy all the [ __ ]
[Music]
your whole party's thinking did we
online oh [ __ ] I'm saying you live in
your [ __ ] learn here on the church
periscope I've been telling you people
is the morning joint this is the real
deal Holyfield is where he's showing up
with prosthetics I'm saying you don't
see me with a fake hand and a pike
coming from somewhere this is it
[ __ ] we're here I've got to
open up the door before somebody calls
and I want one give me two minutes
[Music]
oh [ __ ] will back the sunshine Dracula
left the building this is a bad [ __ ]
[ __ ] vapor pen somebody dropped
on us we tried it the other day the
links hypnose zero [ __ ] tremendously
links hypnose zero you get one of these
it has the [ __ ] vapor pen would you
could do this for wax war that's the
real deal you know what I'm not a wax do
I had a little bag out of container
white sitting somewhere
it's [ __ ] tremendous you know in case
there's an apocalyptic [ __ ] they drop
and I'm not a week I got wax then [ __ ]
the ones you just smoked we do that a
small but this is one of the case the
one I gotta have brought this here for
leak
it's [ __ ] tremendous it's like a meal
he said the taste will be different
taste better you know give it a try if
you're out there the links Hypno's zero
always dropping something - a you
[ __ ] the second egg on I was
looking for a vapor pen Joey
this [ __ ] knows exactly what I
need one week another pocket well you
look like my next one the Prince of
Darkness [ __ ] checking in with
you guys the minute look at them dancing
this [ __ ] this is Aussie right now you
[ __ ] you know they buck them off they
gave steroids good this [ __ ] life
this is for Timmy Halloween [ __ ] I'm
Secaucus New Jersey
[Music]
hey listen we got all packs
entertainment brief early puppets we
don't [ __ ] around this I'm giving you on
a 50% if you don't like it hang up the
[ __ ] phone what do you say me saying
Joe we don't play ed Oh do something
else go eat your wife's [ __ ] [ __ ]
I know if I'd be home by now 6:30 after
dinner the kids in the room playing with
blocks
you want dessert [ __ ] the rice pudding
tell you why bend over let me sniff that
hairy [ __ ] muff I didn't shave it I
want to see long hairs people were
having a good [ __ ] time if you can't
have a good [ __ ] time I don't know
what to tell you it's pre fourth of July
most people sit there watching 60
minutes get scared to fly shave for two
[ __ ] months it's all over you know
[Music]
everybody gets the same treatment just
like me in the 40 year old virgin when
I'm uncle Joey coming at you with his
[ __ ] main man please sighs look at
these eyeballs there's a real eyeballs
right there
you see that in training [ __ ]
he got his last week he lost two strikes
will he on the ferris wheel
he lost two strikes before that with the
[ __ ] Nazi knee and the [ __ ]
brownies with no war but they got two
strikes back so you all right you back
up the [ __ ] great class whatever
anyway what do people think of the house
anything good we're gonna start here in
a couple of minutes
you know I love you [ __ ] I
wouldn't be here killing myself doing
this [ __ ] if I didn't love you guys
wrong my heart what is it time for
another bump
thank you for mentioning it let me just
warp the [ __ ] throw a little bit oh
you know same head over to the family
these things but she's busted a limo
right now Donald you don't just sit
there
[ __ ] I don't know what's with the
questions home wait you want to ask me
Errol technology questions I don't know
about that all I know is you put weed in
the [ __ ] thing you go like this
let the pigeons loose it's a quarter the
[ __ ] ten East Coast time it's over
for you [ __ ] eat those valleys
pull them Michael Jackson tell the
doctors you gotta go get milk
cuz you're going deep with the river hit
song I'm paying you big money and why I
believe the bag Emily leaves the bag you
[ __ ] GUI yourself up it's over when
they come back you're all glued up yeah
I'm saying way [ __ ] sticky Charlie
Thank You Louise a good man he's a
painter takes a little easiest no way
you [ __ ] you just sit there by the
time yeah
what the [ __ ] get it together uncle Joey
loves you in Sunday right now I should
be with my family
then I sacrifice that [ __ ] to people you
[ __ ] y4k because I love you
that's what 4k means why in Spanish
[Music]
forget about the Upton things happen but
don't worry about them for Joey's here
we went through this last bottle and
I'll send you on your way you've got a
good [ __ ] family understand me I love
you people with all my [ __ ] heart
they'll never forget
the no expectations' tour starts in Los
Angeles July 21st place don't quote me
on I think it's a flatus I got a few
dates at the ice house there are two
dates at the Comedy Store you know me
I'm international political Pete if I'm
gonna give you this special gotta work
this [ __ ] out
[Music]
police what are you doing here get out
of here you will be back except that you
two
[Music]